A key technology for timesharing is the periodic
interrupt from the external timer device.
Let's remind ourselves how the interrupt hardware
in the Beta works.
External devices request an interrupt by asserting
the Beta's interrupt request (IRQ) input.
If the Beta is running in user mode, i.e.,
the supervisor bit stored in the PC is 0,
asserting IRQ will trigger the following actions
on the clock cycle the interrupt is recognized.
The goal is to save the current PC+4 value
in the XP register and force the program counter
(PC) to a particular kernel-mode instruction,
which starts the execution of the interrupt
handler code.
The normal process of generating control signals
based on the current instruction is superseded
by forcing particular values for some of the
control signals.
PCSEL is set to 4, which selects a specified
kernel-mode address as the next value of the
program counter.
The address chosen depends on the type of
external interrupt.
In the case of the timer interrupt, the address
is 0x80000008.
Note that PC[31], the supervisor bit, is being
set to 1 and the CPU will be in kernel-mode
as it starts executing the code of the interrupt
handler.
The WASEL, WDSEL, and WERF control signals
are set so that PC+4 is written into the XP
register (i.e., R30) in the register file.
And, finally, MWR is set to 0 to ensure that
if we're interrupting a ST instruction that
its execution is aborted correctly.
So in the next clock cycle, execution starts
with the first instruction of the kernel-mode
interrupt handler,
which can find the PC+4 of the interrupted
instruction in the XP register of the CPU.
As we can see the interrupt hardware is pretty
minimal:
it saves the PC+4 of the interrupted user-mode
program in the XP register and sets the program
counter to some predetermined value that depends
on which external interrupt happened.
The remainder of the work to handle the interrupt
request is performed in software.
The state of the interrupted process, e.g.,
the values in the CPU registers R0 through
R30, is stored in main memory in an OS data
structure called UserMState.
Then the appropriate handler code, usually
a procedure written in C, is invoked to do
the heavy lifting.
When that procedure returns, the process state
is reloaded from UserMState.
The OS subtracts 4 from the value in XP, making
it point to the interrupted instruction and
then resumes user-mode execution with a JMP(XP).
Note that in our simple Beta implementation
the first instructions for the various interrupt
handlers occupy consecutive locations in main
memory.
Since interrupt handlers are longer than one
instruction, this first instruction is invariably
a branch to the actual interrupt code.
Here we see that the reset interrupt (asserted
when the CPU first starts running) sets the
PC to 0, the illegal instruction interrupt
sets the PC to 4, the timer interrupt sets
the PC to 8, and so on.
In all cases, bit 31 of the new PC value is
set to 1 so that handlers execute in supervisor
or kernel mode, giving them access to the
kernel context.
A common alternative is provide a table of
new PC values at a known location and have
the interrupt hardware access that table to
fetch the PC for the appropriate handler routine.
This provides the same functionality as our
simple Beta implementation.
Since the process state is saved and restored
during an interrupt, interrupts are transparent
to the running user-mode program.
In essence, we borrow a few CPU cycles to
deal with the interrupt, then it's back to
normal program execution.
Here's how the timer interrupt handler would
work.
Our initial goal is to use the timer interrupt
to update a data value in the OS that records
the current time of day (TOD).
Let's assume the timer interrupt is triggered
every 1/60th of a second.
A user-mode program executes normally, not
needing to make any special provision to deal
with timer interrupts.
Periodically the timer interrupts the user-mode
program to run the clock interrupt handler
code in the OS, then resumes execution of
the user-mode program.
The program continues execution just as if
the interrupt had not occurred.
If the program needs access to the TOD, it
makes the appropriate service request to the
OS.
The clock handler code in the OS starts and
ends with a small amount of assembly-language
code to save and restore the state.
In the middle, the assembly code makes a C
procedure call to actually handle the interrupt.
Here's what the handler code might look like.
In C, we find the declarations for the TOD
data value and the structure, called UserMState,
that temporarily holds the saved process state.
There's also the C procedure for incrementing
the TOD value.
A timer interrupt executes the BR() instruction
at location 8, which branches to the actual
interrupt handler code at CLOCK_H.
The code first saves the values of all the
CPU registers into the UserMState data structure.
Note that we don't save the value of R31 since
its value is always 0.
After setting up the kernel-mode stack, the
assembly-language stub calls the C procedure
above to do the hard work.
When the procedure returns, the CPU registers
are reloaded from the saved process state
and the XP register value decremented by 4
so that it will point to the interrupted instruction.
Then a JMP(XP) resumes user-mode execution.
Okay, that was simple enough.
But what does this all have to do with timesharing?
Wasn't our goal to arrange to periodically
switch which process was running?
Aha!
We have code that runs on every timer interrupt,
so let's modify it so that every so often
we arrange to call the OS' Scheduler() routine.
In this example, we'd set the constant QUANTUM
to 2 if we wanted to call Scheduler() every
second timer interrupt.
The Scheduler() subroutine is where the time
sharing magic happens!
Here we see the UserMState data structure
from the previous slide where the user-mode
process state is stored during interrupts.
And here's an array of process control block
(PCB) data structures, one for each process
in the system.
The PCB holds the complete state of a process
when some other process is currently executing
- it's the long-term storage for processor
state!
As you can see, it includes a copy of MState
with the process' register values, the MMU
state, and various state associated with the
process' input/output activities,
represented here by a number indicating which
virtual user-interface console is attached
to the process.
There are N processes altogether.
The variable CUR gives the index into ProcTable
for the currently running process.
And here's the surprisingly simple code for
implementing timesharing.
Whenever the Scheduler() routine is called,
it starts by moving the temporary saved state
into the PCB for the current process.
It then increments CUR to move to the next
process, making sure it wraps back around
to 0 when we've just finished running the
last of the N processes.
It then loads reloads the temporary state
from the PCB of the new process and sets up
the MMU appropriately.
At this point Scheduler() returns and the
clock interrupt handler reloads the CPU registers
from the updated temporary saved state and
resumes execution.
Voila!
We're now running a new process.
Let's use this diagram to once again walk
through how time sharing works.
At the top of the diagram you'll see the code
for the user-mode processes, and below the
OS code along with its data structures.
The timer interrupts the currently running
user-mode program and starts execution of
the OS' clock handler code.
The first thing the handler does is save all
the registers into the UserMState data structure.
If the Scheduler() routine is called, it moves
the temporarily saved state into the PCB,
which provides the long-term storage for a
process' state.
Next, Scheduler() copies the saved state for
the next process into the temporary holding
area.
Then the clock handler reloads the updated
state into the CPU registers and resumes execution,
this time running code in the new process.
While we're looking at the OS, note that since
its code runs with the supervisor mode bit
set to 1, interrupts are disabled while in
the OS.
This prevents the awkward problem of getting
a second interrupt while still in the middle
of handling a first interrupt, a situation
that might accidentally overwrite the state
in UserMState.
But that means one has to be very careful
when writing OS code.
Any sort of infinite loop can never be interrupted.
You may have experienced this when your machine
appears to freeze, accepting no inputs and
just sitting there like a lump.
At this point, your only choice is to power-cycle
the hardware (the ultimate interrupt!) and
start afresh.
Interrupts are allowed during execution of
user-mode programs, so if they run amok and
need to be interrupted, that's always possible
since the OS is still responding to, say,
keyboard interrupts.
Every OS has a magic combination of keystrokes
that is guaranteed to suspend execution of
the current process, sometimes arranging to
make a copy of the process state for later
debugging.
Very handy!